on Monday I became a father never
actually said that before out loud and
it still kind of astonishes me surprised
Anderson Cooper is a dad this is Wyatt
Cooper he is three days old is named
after my dad who died when I was 10
years old I hope I can be as good a dad
as he was on Thursday the CNN anchor
revealed that he welcomed a baby boy
Wyatt Morgan Cooper via a surrogate
Anderson explained Morgan is a family
name from his mom Gloria Vanderbilt side
he recently found a list of possible
baby names his parents considered for
him Morgan was on it so that's Wyatt
Morgan Cooper my son he was he was 7.2
pounds at birth and he is sweet and soft
and healthy and I am beyond happy the
journalist got emotional talking about
his newborn son fighting back tears I do
wish my mom and my dad and my brother
Carter were alive to meet Wyatt but I
like to believe that they can see him I
imagine them all together arms around
each other smiling and laughing and
watching looking down on us happy to
know that their love is alive in me and
in Wyatt and that our family continues
Anderson also shared the happy news on
Instagram too posting these sweet pics
of his itty-bitty as a gay kid I never
thought it would be possible to have a
child and I'm so grateful for all those
who paved the way and for the doctors
and nurses and everyone involved in my
son's birth fans and friends like busy
Phillips Billy Eichner Leslie Jordan Don
Lemon and Carly cloths were quick to hit
up social media to congratulate Anderson
on his three day old bundle of joy Andy
Cohen shared this shot writing Wyatt
Cooper you couldn't have come at a
better time I'm just so happy for you
and he could not be more lucky he's got
one of the smartest most deeply caring
people as his father that I've ever met
in my life you could be a great day
shortly after anderson revealed the big
news on air
Cuomo dropped some heartfelt words on
the new dad you will honor the memory of
your loved ones in the way you never
imagined through how you love this kid
and your wasp es is gonna emote in a way
that you never you're gonna cry with a
frequency you're never imagined but he
looks at you what he recognizes you you
will see my friend this is going to be
the best thing that ever happened in
your life in his to et was with Anderson
and his mom Gloria back in 2016 before
she died she said she hoped he'd be a
dad one day we still have time Lord
would you like to see Anderson one day
have his had children of his own thanks
for bringing this up this is not as if
this isn't an ongoing issue doesn't
every month or one third kids yes I've
heard this many times believe me I know
the clock is ticking
[Music]